Stone oppressor literally means star
gobblers and they're not just foodies
they're men on a mission they dine and
post a review on their website there are
no formal ratings what they do dish out
are lengthy descriptions complete with
pictures
the name ones me we don't take ourselves
as seriously as regular restaurant
critics do it because we want our
reviews to be light-hearted we want to
focus on how enjoyable the meals are in
spasm isn't an admitted home stone today
we're paying a visit to the Schloss
hotel layer buck nickel owned the
restaurant boasts two Michelin stars and
the palatial surroundings don't hurt
either the testers usually announced
that they're coming only one of the four
food buffs actually does this full-time
they normally come in pairs to get two
different perspectives their first
impressions are not all that convincing
it's a little on the sweet side and it's
stuck to my molars apparently the
proportions aren't quite perfect but as
they admit themselves at this level of
gourmet dining the complaints are
nothing more than a quibble a McClung of
7vm we're traveling abroad in a major
city like Paris or London
we might take in eight restaurants in
just four days that's all we have time
for it's hard work because you have to
take a very emotional approach but here
in Germany we usually do two or three
restaurants a week I do you want Omaha
for chefs the website isn't just where
they're judged and measured the pros
read it for information too it gets
around eighty thousand views a month
chef Nils Henkel wants to know what's
being said about his restaurant and
that's not all I saw the Java TiVo hi
check the site at least once a week for
the latest news there's a lot of
information there that's really
interesting for people in the industry
to like me and I can't be expected to
know everything on my own
they're very well connected and they're
well informed - so it's good to log on
and check out what they have to say
the Lemire restaurant on the North Sea
Island of Zulte is run by Sebastian Cyr
he agrees the blog is essential reading
this I know you're simply a new fresh
and modern medium that reaches people
who don't have much interest in the
Mishnah or call me or Wieslaw of Amiens
at Kuwahara the photos are key to the
online presentations they're taken at
the table not in the kitchen
it's like a visual appetizer that lets
the diners know what awaits them the
names the collecting of course we don't
like to give away too much of our
reports take a couple of weeks to finish
and go online by then the menu will have
changed if a guest goes to a top
restaurant looking for a specific dish
they'll probably find a completely
different selection and they find that
this unpretentious culinary creation
goes down the trees as discreet -
Umberto from Berlin and Ebert no.15
especially its fan so we're fans of
gourmet eating so there's always
excitement and anticipation but we're
also very critical and get I'd perhaps
even more focused on detail than some
conventional critics of Mancha
conventionally categorize - inverter
the bloggers evaluate the complete
package food staff and service and now
for the grand finale at the Schloss
hotel ever the final verdict after their
ten-course meal delicious